man: Welcome to Google I/O.
[upbeat music]
[man singing indistinctly]
♫offline functionality improved access-ability de-crease your la-ten-cy♫
♫more fast applications with persistent storage and cacheable resources♫
♫rich in-browser video and audio (no plugin yo) geolocation api enables apps for on the go♫
♫write your multimedia, location service with regular javascript♫
♫query up and down your client-side, executing SQL states.♫
♫put my files inside your manifest to startup fast♫
♫see and play all of your buttons; attribute "controls"♫
♫vector graphics client-side, with drag drop from low to high mean high-fi-del-ity UIs♫
♫immersive experience. dynamic images, drawings and drag events♫
♫independent background scripts performing computation tricks, communication APIs for multi-origin post events♫
♫maintain page responsiveness, execute workers, safe cross-domain messages♫
♫pose your polygons because i'm gonna paint in JS♫
♫take it off, put it down, move around, never stop♫
♫i'm running tasks behind your back, but you will never be disturbed♫
♫vector graphics client-side, with drag drop from low to high mean high-fi-del-ity UIs♫
♫immersive experience. dynamic images, drawings and drag events♫
♫independent background scripts performing computation tricks, communication APIs for multi-origin post events♫
♫maintain page responsiveness, execute workers, safe cross-domain messages♫
♫pose your polygons because i'm gonna paint in JS♫
♫take it off, put it down, move around, never stop♫
♫i'm running tasks behind your back, but you will never be disturbed♫
man: Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Chief Executive Officer of Google,
Dr. Eric Schmidt.
Schmidt: Thank you.
[applause]
Thank you all.
First let me start by welcoming everybody.
Many of you traveled a long distance
to come here to, uh, spend two days with us
to talk about the thing I like the most,
which is programming.
And let me tell you that it's time.
It's time for us to take advantage
of the amazing opportunity that is before us.
And that's what I want to talk about
for just a few minutes.
Today and tomorrow,
you're going to have interesting product announcements,
some fun stuff, and perhaps most important,
you're gonna spend time
with the best programmers in the world
who are here in the room.
Literally you all.
And we're very excited to have you here.
Uh, from my perspective, it's time.
trying to build a programming model
that's the right one.
We started with the mainframe model.
Then we moved to the PC model.
And it had brilliant parts and very frustrating parts.
And then the internet arrived.
And internet programming.
The way we think about it now
is something we have all worked on
for all of our career.
It's time.
Why is it time?
We finally now have the networks,
the businesses, the programmers,
the programming tools,
that can build the kind of platforms
and the kind of opportunities that I want to highlight.
Today and tomorrow, you're going to hear a lot
about some of the Google technologies
many of you, you--you are already using.
For example, Google Web--Web Toolkit.
You know, we used to say "write once,
run anywhere with Java" back in my old--
in my old job.
Now it's write "write once, run on any browser," right?
Uh, because the browsers have become so complicated.
That's what GWT is all about.
We're going to see a lot more things
about a product called App Engine,
which now today includes, by the way,
support for Java, right, which is great,
and more, presumably, coming.
The notion of these platforms as powerful platforms
are part of a story that's been true forever.
And it's a story that innovation always occurs elsewhere.
It never is in the little world that I sit in
or that you sit in.
It's always somewhere else.
There's always a programmer, an inventor,
a brilliant person
who's somewhere other than where you are.
They need to use a platform that you build.
They need, for example, to be able to use a platform
even if they don't speak English
and even if they don't really understand
some of the other things that you've done,
but because they have an idea and they have a vision.
And maybe they use the wrong operating system
or they have the wrong background
or whatever,
but they're clever and they're smart.
And that's how innovation occurs.
It's always been true and it will always be true.
And that's why we're here today.
Maybe you're here to talk about Android
and some of the things that we're doing there.
Android looks like it's going to have a very strong year.
Not only do we have many thousands
of applications now
as part of our Android application store,
but we also have many hardware partners
that are coming along
to build innovative new hardware platforms
which look like phones,
but do a lot of things
that--that are not normally associated with phones.
Again, the innovation cycle continues.
So what we want you to do is we want you here
to spend your time with our teams and vice versa
and yourselves with each other
to try to figure out what we can do now.
So why is it time? Why is it time?
Why is it time to take the challenge?
Because people are frustrated.
They're tired of the complexity
of all of the systems that have been built up
They don't work that well.
Where's the "it works" option?
Where's the button where it just installs and works?
Why do we keep adding complexity after complexity in our--
in our world?
Well, here's an opportunity using Ajax programming,
the new programming languages,
the new programming paradigm that we're going to talk about
in the next couple of days to build another step higher.
To bring another level of functionality
that ultimately means power can generate simplicity
and ultimately make these systems
simpler and easier to use
by the people we serve who are not programmers.
They're not computer scientists.
They're not engineers.
I'm one of these people who believes
that computer science
is at the center of the universe.
I'm one of these people who believes
that what we do as scientists, as programmers,
as people who care about making the world
a better place,
can really scale.
I'm a person who believes that scalability
and the power as r-- as evidenced by the power
of the internet is just beginning.
And I would tell you that we're just at the beginning
of getting this right.
When we talk about cloud computing,
we talk about all the new kinds of devices,
you're seeing a whole new set of companies, ideas,
product solutions, competitors.
All sorts of things all coming from this shared vision
around a new programming model.
It's not the old programming model
where I was handed a book and said program
against these interfaces against this standard OS
and everything will work locally.
But it's a similar model
where I can go pick the very best
of this code and that code.
Put it together. Mash it if you will.
Have it automatically compiled.
And have it deliver tremendous performance
for all of us.
With this, we can take the collective intelligence
of the internet, which is astounding--
all the information, all those things going on--
and do amazing things.
We can tell people what's going to happen.
We can tell people what's happening nearby.
We can follow what they care about.
As you walk down the street,
we can tell them the history of the buildings
as we walk along.
We can do image recognition to sort of see what's happening.
All of these are applications that someone in this room
has already built.
All of you are busy building
of all of those kinds of things.
It's phenomenal.
So my message to you is this is the beginning
of the real win of cloud computing.
Of the real win of applications.
Of the real win of the internet,
which is changing the computing paradigm--
the one that we've all grown up with--
so it just works.
It works no matter what device you're using,
whatever operating system you're using,
as long as you're connected--
and even if you're no-- offline with some caching,
you're on and you have everything you need.
That's the promise of our new web computing model,
which we're all talking about.
We're going to show you some amazing technology
and some amazing partnerships that we've done
in the next hour and a half.
I'm delighted that you're here
and I'm excited about what we're doing.
And I want to take a minute to thank you for coming
and also introduce Vic Gundrota,
who's the executive who's in charge
of all of our develop programs, all of our mobile programs,
and lots of our businesses.
Vic, can you join me on stage?
Thank you very much.
Gundrota: Thank you, Eric. Schmidt: Take care, Vic.
Gundrota: Appreciate it. Schmidt: Thanks.
Gundrota: Thank you. Schmidt: Thank you.
[applause]
Gundrota: Thank you for those opening comments, Eric.
And good morning, everybody. Welcome to I/O.
Never underestimate the web.
It's a mistake that I once made.
It was about a half a decade ago
and I was leading a team at Microsoft responsible
for driving the developer adoption of Windows.
Of course we had seen the emergence of the web.
But we argued that web apps could never rival desktop apps.
In fact, our favorite and our canonical example
was from a small Bay Area company called Keyhole.
Keyhole had made the fan--
most fantastic geovisualization software
for Windows.
And it was exactly that kind of software
that we argued could never be done on the web.
Google acquired that small company
and a few months later released maps.google.com
with satellite views.
A web app that simply left us stunned.
Maybe you remember the first time you
from any browser were able to zoom down
into your own backyard.
You know, Google Apps-- Google Maps was amazing--
is amazing.
But what was even more important was what that application
was foretelling.
That we would see what we formerly thought
was impossible become possible,
even commonplace in the browser.
Yes, the web has won.
It has become the dominant programming model of our time.
In many respects, this conference, Google I/O,
is about a celebration of that open web platform.
And this morning, I'd like to talk to you
about the ongoing evolution of--of the web.
Of making a more powerful web made easier.
And this morning's keynote is broken up
into two broad sections.
In the opening section,
I'm going to show you,
uh, what's making the web more powerful.
that are enabling us to build applications
that I think will surprise users.
And in the second half of the keynote,
I'm going to highlight some Google services
that we believe can help you, uh, build those apps
much easier.
So let's get started here.
Let me find the clicker.
You know, I think when you look back over the last year--
in fact, just the last eight, nine months--
you have to be amazed
at the rate our web platform is accelerating.
It seems like almost every other month,
we've had a browser released
even--either for the desktop or for mobile.
And these new browsers are not just faster--
I mean, of course they're faster--
but even more importantly,
these browsers are incorporating .NET new functionality
that, frankly, I'm not sure most developers know about.
Gundrota: This new functionality that's, uh, included
in these browsers allows developers
to have their cake and eat it too.
We still get the best of the web browser
deployment model-- the friction-free deployment--
and for the first time as developers,
we're able to access the underlying services
such as geolocation or the graphic subsystem
or storage or CPU services
in a way that was formerly only limited
to native applications.
And those capabilities, we believe,
will close the remaining gap in usability and performance
from native apps and web applications
even further.
Course, it's not just about the technology.
It's about people.
It's about the people in this room.
Those who've contributed to this amazing acceleration
of innovation that we've seen.
This chart is the unique, monthly contributors,
um, to open source projects.
And just look at the growth of our community--
of developers contributing to make the web better.
And so it's no surprise that as our community grows,
we see more innovation.
I mean, just stop for a moment.
Did you realize that in the last decade,
we have seen
in JavaScript parsing?
Think about the implications.
The implications are that what we thought was impossible
to do in the browser with JavaScript
may now become possible.
Of course, that's just one example
of technological improvement.
We're going to show you lots more today.
More the community growing, more innovation,
has lead to the ultimate metric of success,
which is users.
And today, we have almost half a billion people
who are using modern, open source browsers.
And I think that is just a fantastic testimony
to the success that we as a community have had
in moving the web forward.
I'm gonna walk you through some new capabilities
in what I'm going
We believe that the capabilities that I'm about to show you
in this keynote allow us
but really move to kind of apps that have capability,
have a fidelity, have an experience
that I think will surprise you.
Before I go into those new standards,
I want to tell a cautionary tale
and I want to plead for help from you.
Almost a decade ago,
I was on another team responsible
for driving the adoption of XMLHttpRequest.
It was a new capability we had added to the browser
that allowed for asynchronous callback.
And I talked to many companies, many developers,
and we just didn't get traction
until--do you know when?
when Google released Gmail
and we saw an explosion of Ajax apps.
Yet those underlying capabilities
that enabled those Ajax applications
had laid dormant in the browser
for over half a decade
because no killer apps were developed
that exploited those capabilities.
I'm going to plead with you as a community,
let's not make the same mistake again.
As we talk about these new standards this morning
recognize that having the capability
in the underlying platform is not enough.
It's up to you and people like Google--
companies like Google and others--
to build the compelling apps
that are exploitive of these capabilities.
Let's not wait another half decade.
Let's take advantage of these things
that you'll see this morning.
Let's build those exploitive apps.
Let's move the web forward even faster.
So this morning, I'm going to invite up Matt Waddell
to walk us through--
we're gonna go through
You're going to see a lot of the capabilities
we're talking about.
And Matt, my colleague, is going to walk through these demos
as I--as I talk over them.
We're going to emphasize five things
that excite Google
and we think you should be paying attention to
The first one is canvas.
Let's talk about the problem.
You're developers.
How do you draw a diagonal line in the browser?
Think about it. What do you do?
Draw a diagonal line in the browser.
Well, I know, you think, well, Vic,
I guess you can't really draw a diagonal line in the browser.
You would draw and image on the server.
You'd push the image down
and you'd get your diagonal line.
Yeah, you're right.
But then, of course, your interactivity
is limited to the granularity of the image tag.
That's not very interactive.
Some of you in the audience are going, wait, wait,
it's easier than that.
Just use a VML or Silverlight or Flash.
And--and you're right. Those approaches could work.
But what if we wanted something that was part of the open,
transparent internet that we know and love?
And that's exactly what canvas is.
The canvas tag is intrinsic. It's native.
It fits seamlessly into the page
and works great with JavaScript and CSS and the DOM.
And canvas allows you as a developer
for the first time within the browser
to have drawing and animation APIs
with pixel-level control,
which changes, uh, the kind of applications
we can deliver.
Let me show you.
In the first example we're going to show--
if we could switch to the demo machine--
Matt is just going to draw within, uh, the browser.
And he's using the mouse. He's drawing.
The magic here is in the source code.
That's the entire source code.
There are no plug-ins here.
What's magical is what Matt is highlighting.
There's the use of the canvas tag.
And then the JavaScript is doing nothing more
than responding to mouse up and mouse down movements.
And he's drawing right there within the browser.
Let's show you a little bit more advanced example.
This is a first-person, uh, shooter--
I mean, gifter.
We did this on Mother's Day.
And we thought first-person shooter
was not politically correct so we changed his--
the weapon.
I guess he runs around giving gifts.
Uh, but once again, the magic here,
look at the JavaScript.
It's the use of the canvas tag and nothing more
than--than JavaScript.
And, you know, this is-- this is amazing.
That kind of demo half a decade ago
or a decade ago was amazing on the PC.
Now you can do that within the browser.
This next example is Bespin.
It's a development tool from Mozilla Labs.
It's an IDE that allows you to build web apps.
And it's, uh, it's a fascinating tool.
What's interesting about the IDE
is that it feels like a native app.
It's not a native app. This is in the browser.
And the use of canvas tags to do pixel-level control
gives this Bespin IDE tool a level of richness
and a native feel
that I don't think you're used to in the browser.
Finally, let me show you another example.
This is an internal tool.
We've never demonstrated this publicly.
We've never shown this.
It's a tool we use at Google to do profiling,
um, uh, uh, characteristics,
um, and so we can tweak our apps
and make them faster and better.
So we can switch to, uh, machine two.
And what Matt's going to do is this is--
this is running in Chrome.
He's going to click on the tab.
And he--he turned on this profiling tool
that you see him moving to the right.
Now he's going to open an article
in The New York Times.
Yeah, I don't think you clicked on that article.
There we go.
Now, as he, uh, goes to that article,
what will happen is that profiling tool
will start to graph,
uh, the--the performance characteristics
of--of that particular operation.
Note how he can zoom in to that profiling tool.
Those spikes represent time
or things that are slowing down the app.
And as he moves up and down, he can see the various events.
Matt, can you click-- there we go.
So he opened up a script tag.
You can see the pie chart there
that shows what percent of the time
was on the JavaScript compile,
what percent was on parsing the HTML
and so forth.
So the tool is interesting.
But would you believe that tool is completely built
that's just the use of a canvas tag
to produce this level of high fidelity?
It's an example of the kind of apps
that we as a community can build
once we have pixel-level control on the screen.
Let's go back to the slides.
Course, one of the advantages of using,
uh, something like canvas
is that you as the developer get to take advantage
of performance improvements in the browser.
So as JavaScript continues to get faster,
you get to ride that rocket
and automatically benefit from that.
Course, we've shown you some examples
of canvas to produce
We think it might be.
In fact, I'd like to invite up Matt Papakipos
up to the stage
uh, and some emerging standards
that we think will surprise you.
Matt.
Papakipos: I got to go, right? Gundrota: We've lost Matt.
Aha! There he is. Matt, please.
Papakipos: Thank you, Vic.
[applause]
So I'm Matt--Matt Papakipos.
I run, uh, one of the-- one of the efforts
in the Chrome team at Google.
Um, we are very excited about the prospects
inside the web browser.
And we'd like to share with you,
uh, what we've been working on today.
Over the last ten years,
we've seen an explosion
that real users use every day.
Everything from video games to engineering applications
to data visualizations like Google Earth.
What's been missing thus far is the ability
applications
in the browser itself.
So let me show you what we've been working on.
developed at Google,
that we open sourced a little over a month ago today.
You can find this on code.google.com.
So what are we looking at?
We're looking at rich,
running in the browser.
It's a JavaScript API
that a conventional web application can use
functionality
whenever you want in your app.
As you can see, we're running it here in Chrome.
But it also runs in Firefox and IE and Safari and Opera.
This, uh, the application we're running
is what we call our beach demo.
It's one of the many code samples we developed
that the technology worked
and performed.
Uh, and it's open sourced on code.google.com.
So the--the full source code of the JavaScript
and all the art assets are fully open sourced.
Papakipos: So you've probably seen
graphics like this before in games
or in other applications.
What you haven't seen is in--
seen this running intrinsically in the web browser.
So the technology clearly has great potential.
Let me walk you through some of the interesting aspects
of--of this demo, uh, to show you more about it.
So first off, notice the visual quality here.
We have very high resolution texture maps
on the surfaces of the rocks, of the trees,
of the bottom, uh, of the--the sea floor
under the water, and of the sky itself.
We also have what are called bump maps.
So we have, um, detailed textures
on the surfaces that describe the local surface texture--
the physical shape of the surface--
which gives us very realistic lighting
as the light bounces off the scene
and--and, uh, hits the viewer.
We're also doing some very advanced
shading techniques, uh, on the water.
So you can see that we've implemented
reflection and refraction.
And these are coded right in the source code
of the application so the application can control
the visual appearance of the water
or other attributes of the scene.
The next thing that we focused on
was performance.
So you'll notice we're running
It gives it this very smooth, liquid feel
like you're really there, you're in the scene.
Um, the same, uh, level of performance
that you would expect to see
from, uh, from a native application
running on the operating system.
And here we're seeing it in the browser.
The other interesting aspect
is we're doing all of the graphics
on the graphics processor, on the GPU.
So the CPU load as we run this application
So the CPU is still there for you to use
in your JavaScript code and by the browser
to implement your application logic,
which is extremely important.
Uh, and then the last point about the demo
that's interesting is it's all JavaScript code.
So you have all the nice attributes
of JavaScript for web development.
You can edit the code right on your machine,
test it on your machine, deploy it easily.
Uh, no complicated build process.
It's just JavaScript.
So this is very cool technology.
But we still have a long way to go
until we achieve our dream.
Where we want to get to is the point
where you type a URL in the address bar,
uh, go to a web site, and play a rich,
application.
In order for this to happen,
we need this capability to be built into the browsers
by default.
So we need a common set of APIs
that are implemented widely by all the dominant--
all the-- all the browser vendors
so that your browser of choice does this intrinsically.
It becomes a feature of the browser itself.
The key here is standardization.
So we're--we at Google are working very closely
with Apple, Mozilla, Opera, and others
in the context of the standards organizations,
to make this a reality.
So we still have a ways to go.
But we've begun the process of standardization
will work on the web.
We invite you to join that discussion.
The other thing is we have to put it
in the browser itself.
And so we're hard at work at Google
capabilities like these
into the Chromium code base
so that Chrome has the ability to do this
without the need of any plug-in whatsoever.
So we're very excited about the directions
these are--this is going.
So this is all very cool. It looks neat.
It's very fun.
It's nice to see the web gain these capabilities.
Uh, but it's still just a demo.
We're still in the very early phase.
This is a plug-in today.
We're very excited about the future.
The other key to the puzzle here is applications.
Uh, we want to see real world applications emerge
where you and people like you make applications
in web sites that use these capabilities
to their full advantage.
What is the next killer
on your web site?
Is it a game? Is it data visualization?
Is it an engineering application?
Is it something new?
So we're very excited about the prospects
for the future.
We hope you will check it out and, uh, join us
in, uh, pushing it over the finish line.
[applause]
Gundrota: Obviously, if you'd like to learn more
about what Matt just showed you,
there's the URL and you can get all the details
in addition to the sessions that we're having on it.
Going back to the canvas capability,
remember, uh, developers are not going to use canvas
if it isn't broadly available.
And we're very happy to report
that across all modern, open source browsers,
uh, Chrome, Firefox, Safari,
we have this capability.
I hear some of the laughter.
You must be wondering why I didn't mention
Internet Explorer.
Uh, let me talk about that briefly.
Obviously, Microsoft,
with its very large market share,
could do much to move the web forward.
And so you can imagine how excited we were
to hear Microsoft's public statements
about their commitment
And, uh, that very, very much excites us.
And we eagerly await to see, uh, evidence of that.
[audience laughs]
That's all I'm going to mention about IE today.
Now that I've danced past that elephant,
let's move on.
Uh, let's talk about video.
Just like I asked you with canvas,
let me ask you with video.
How do you play video in a browser today?
You know, as a developer, you really have a tough job.
You got to ensure that your users
have the correct plug-in installed, uh,
in their browser.
In addition to having a plug-in stalled,
you got to ask yourself "does that plug-in support
"the appropriate codec that's going to--
that that video is encoded in?"
And there's some variables that are outside of your control
as a developer.
So video is hard.
You might ask yourself if you were responsible
for moving the web forward, what would Occam do?
Well, how about a video tag as simple as image.
video gives you.
A simple tag where you point it to the source
and the browser handles the rest.
Let me show you some examples.
Let's go to machine one.
man: Billy's been trying to customize his web browser.
man: This'll make it go faster.
Gundrota: Okay, that's-- that's one way
to make the web go faster.
Uh, it's a--it's a video playing in the--in the browser.
No big deal until you look at the source code.
And you look at the source code here
and you can see use of the video tag
to play that video
and nothing more than JavaScript to play and stop it.
Of course, because it's integrated
right within the browser-- let's go back to that demo--
one of the benefits is, like, fo--
I can start a rotate.
This is just a simple JavaScript CSS transform.
And look, I'm rotating the video.
I can even play it if I wanted to.
But it gives you a sense of--of the advantage
of using something that's intrinsic
to that web programming model.
DOM manipulation just like any other element
with the video tag.
Let's go on to the next demonstration.
This is an experiment.
We are not announcing today that YouTube
is going to be built this way.
This is a demo that we just wanted to show you
to get the creative juices going.
Uh, obviously, YouTube is a sight
that you no doubt know and love.
Uh, this looks like YouTube.
In fact, there's a-- one change
that's pretty significant,
which is if you actually look at the source here,
it's implemented using the video tag.
And because it's implemented using the video tag,
those videos play and they're intrinsic
to that, uh, HTML page.
You see as he mouses over the thumbnails,
they just play.
There are--those are not
I'm not marshalling across boundaries.
This is JavaScript, the video tag, and that's it.
And it kind of gives you an example
of where we might be going, uh, in the future.
[applause]
All right, let's--let's go back to the slides.
Once again, very happy to say, across modern browsers,
broad support has been implemented
for the video tag.
Now let's talk about geolocation.
At Google, we believe that almost all kinds of apps
could be better
if they had access to geolocation.
Everything from business software
to social software.
Think about your CRM software if you're a business.
When your sales agent lands in Denver,
why doesn't the CRM software recognize his location
and show him or her the current customers
based on proximity?
In social software,
why isn't the photo automatically geotagged?
Why aren't my updates, my tweets,
uh, automatically tagged with location?
Well, the reality is is that accessing location
and using it is hard today.
You might think, like, what about GPS?
GPS takes a long time to get a fix.
GPS may often not work indoors.
What about IP-- IP-based location?
Well, it's too fuzzy. It's not granular enough.
I mean, heaven forbid your users are AOL users
where the IP has gone through a proxy in Virginia
and all the location reports is Virginia.
And so it hasn't been possible to get good quality data sources
until the last year.
Companies like Skyhook--
companies like Google and others have created
large databases of Wi-Fi data and cell ID data
and really have mapped the entire world with coverage.
These sources combined with GPS and other sources
have now given us the ability to accurately triangulate
or pinpoint an individual's location
with their consent.
Of course, you might be wondering,
well, that's good-- that's great, Vic,
but how do you get it in the browser?
Well, guess what, the last year,
we have seen tremendous progress
with standardization
which is implemented in these browsers.
So you as a developer can take advantage
of these capabilities.
To demonstrate these and kind of talk about them,
I'd like to invite up Jay Sullivan,
Vice President for Mozilla.
Jay, welcome.
Sullivan: Thanks, Vic.
Good to see you.
Gundrota: Jay...
just one moment before you go into your, uh, presentation
and demo here.
I did want to take a moment and just say thank you
to the Mozilla community.
Uh, you know, to a large extent,
we have the luxury this morning of talking
about modern browsers,
Gundrota:
about evolution.
But in reality,
I'm not sure we would've had this luxury
had it not been for Mozilla's and the community's
phenomenal work over ten years.
There was a time when people wondered,
uh, if the--that the odds were against you guys
with, uh, competitors that had the benefit
of preinstallation.
But you guys really proved-- you proved--
that you could build a community of hundreds of millions
of loyal consumers who chose Firefox
and you could build a better web.
So for all that you did, for what you're doing now,
and for what you will do, thank you.
Sullivan: Thanks. Thanks, Vic.
Gundrota: Thank you.
Sullivan: Well, I want to thank Vic
for that introduction.
Um, not for myself,
but on behalf of the whole Mozilla community
around the world that's made that possible.
Um, it's an amazing, vibrant, crazy organization
that it's fun to be a part of.
Um, I want to do three things today, um, real briefly.
I want to explain why Mozilla's here at I/O.
I want to talk about what's coming
in Firefox for developers,
and I want to give you a brief demo
of geolocation support in the browser.
So...
browser competition is heating up again.
That's--that's no secret to anybody here.
Um, and we think this is very important.
As users live more and more of their lives online,
it's very important that we continue
to improve the user experience, to make the browser faster,
and to protect user security and privacy online.
And we see what happens
when there isn't any competition in the marketplace.
Things stagnate. There aren't new features.
The web does not get better.
Now, since we entered the market with Firefox
and other browsers have followed--
these modern browsers that we're talking about today--
that's improved the user experience.
So it's very important to have that vibrant competition
in the marketplace.
And we're glad that these other--
other folks are producing browsers.
Now, it's also important to note that each of our organizations
have very different missions and motivations
for why we work on web browsers.
But today, we put all that aside
to focus on what we share in common.
So we share, I think,
three important things in common.
One, we believe strongly
that the web is the development platform
for our time.
More than any single operating system,
the web is going to drive the innovation
and the new services that are going to do amazing things
for people all around the world.
We also share a belief that we need to keep bringing
new capabilities to you as developers
so you can create these things.
And that means that we need to move quickly.
But also we need to make sure that we don't fragment the web.
There will be no worse outcome
than through this renewed competition
to have a fragmentation of the web platform.
You should be able to focus on--on building your house
and not worrying
about the cross-browser plumbing.
So we need to work together
to--to keep that standards held together.
And that's a challenge. And it's--it's the web.
So it's messy, right?
So we don't always agree on what the perfect API is
to expose a new piece of functionality.
We don't even always agree on the process
to run some experiments and then decide
which the best API should be.
But I strongly believe that a-a very, very good API
for something that's in five browsers
is better than a perfect API that's in no browsers
or one browser.
So we need to work hard together with Google
and the other browser vendors to hold that center.
And that's very important.
I want to talk a little bit about what's coming
for developers.
is the most successful browser
that we've ever built.
users worldwide.
We just recently had our one billionth
add-on download.
phenomenally successful.
But--but we believe
We believe it's much better.
Uh, JavaScript performance,
which is the underlying piece
that dr--that--that enables all of this innovation
in these apps that we're--
that we're working hard to build--
JavaScript performance is three times faster
And ten times faster
So we've been working very hard to increase the speed
of JavaScript execution.
Um, you heard a little bit about how canvas works
and how video works.
And what I think is important here
is getting things like video
out of, uh, out of plug-in prison
so that we can script them.
And when you combine things like video and canvas
as--as Vic demo'ed,
you start to see the power of being able to use things
through--through web APIs
and be able to manipulate them
and mash them up in new ways.
And that's really a common theme
for some of this new functionality
is it's the web.
You should be able to touch anything,
hack anything, and mash up anything.
Um, we're adding support for geolocation.
And I'll talk about that more in a minute.
We're also--we also have support for offline storage
so that you can begin to write apps that work better
when they're disconnected.
That's--that's very important for mobile situations
and--and other use cases.
And we're also adding support for Web Workers
so that you can write scripts that run pretty intensively
without hosing your browser, a very important feature.
And all this stuff is-- is, um, you can--
you can look at the link up there and go there
and it'll take you to a description
of how to use these new APIs
and exactly what the level
Um, I want to talk a little bit now
about geolocation support in the browser.
there's support for, um, the geolocation API.
And I'm going to give you a demo of one of the apps,
um, that's going to use this.
So be believe that there are use cases
in--in many, many, um, spheres
for geolocation support.
Um, we--we think it's going to change how maps,
local search, directions, all sorts of social networking--
anywhere where you want to tag something
with your location,
we believe it's going to change the nature
of how all of those applications work.
One particular application that's going to take advantage
of Firefox's support for geolocation is Google Maps.
So Google Maps, shortly, will be adding a new button
to the user interface called "my location."
And if I click this button, I get a prompt.
And I get request for-- if I would like to share
my location with that web site.
I'm going to go ahead and click share--
I'm going to come back to this
'cause I want to talk about this a little bit.
But I'm going to go ahead and share my location.
Couldn't be determined. Let's try that again.
Okay.
[applause]
Murphy's Law of demos.
Um, so--so I wanted to explain what's happened there.
So, um, what happened when I clicked that button
was the browser gathered up the signal strengths
of all the nearby Wi-Fi hotspots
and transformed that into a latitude and longitude.
If it was a cell phone,
I could've used Wi-Fi
or I could've used cell tower IDs
and the signal strength of those that are nearby.
Um, I could even use GPS if it's local to--to the device.
So there's a number of ways a back-end provider,
uh, can enable that functionality.
And because it's Firefox, user choice is important.
So users will be able to download
all sorts of add-ons that are going to provide
that back-end location functionality.
And web developers can enable their applications
with just a couple lines of JavaScript code.
It's dead simple to use the API.
I want to come back to one thing real briefly though,
which is--which is how a user opts in.
I think this is very important for features like this
that begin to blend services with client-side functionality.
Now, when I click the button, I get this mode list info bar.
Now, don't try to write down the URL.
It's not going to work.
It's behind some Google firewall.
Uh, don't try this at home yet.
Um, so--but I get a-- I get information
about what domain name is requesting my location.
I can click "learn more" if I want to understand
how the service works
and how the privacy policies work.
And if I just ignore this, nothing happens.
If I close it, nothing happens.
If I hit don't share--
and I can remember that not sharing
so that I don't get prompted in the future--
any of those things
and my location is never accessed
by the browser.
It's only if I explicitly opt in.
And that has to happen on a per hostname basis
for this to work.
So we're trying to err on the side
of--of the user being in control.
Even though it might include an extra click here and there,
we think it's important to err on that side.
So, um, that's it for the demo.
We look forward to see the--the great things
you're going to do with geolocation
and with all of these features.
So thanks, Vic.
Gundrota: Thank you. Thank you.
[applause]
Yeah, we love those guys and can't wait to see
what they're going to do next.
Uh, geolocation broadly available
in modern browsers.
Uh, before we move on,
I should show you one more geolocation demo.
Uh, Jay mentioned the importance of using geolocation
in mobile scenarios.
We've got exactly one of those demos to show you.
What you're looking at now is Latitude.
Latitude is an application Google released
several months ago for phones like the BlackBerry,
or Windows Mobile or Nokia phones.
What you're seeing for the first time
is Latitude on the iPhone.
And there's even one more surprise.
It's Latitude on the iPhone in the browser.
And the reason this is possible
is because in the next generation
of Apple's operating system,
they too have implemented
So we're able to build apps that were formerly impossible,
now possible right on the web, uh, uh, on the platform.
You--you'll see this app shortly after Apple releases,
Okay, let's go back to slides.
And by the way, that's another evidence
of Google making the bet
and really try to build those flagship apps
so we can move the web forward.
Now let's move on and talk about App Cache and Database.
Gundrota: As much as we love web apps,
they don't work in many situations
when you lose connectivity
or have intermittent connectivity.
And there are a lot of scenarios
that we wish our web apps could work.
One of the challenges is that there's no local storage
and no way to store the application state or code.
That is until recently.
of Database and App Cache
allow you do is really approach the problem of offline,
or even in the online scenario,
store and cache the resources you need
for a faster application.
Let's show you how this works.
Let's go into the first demo.
First demo, I'm in Safari,
I've got a little app, it creates a sticky note,
and I can, uh, you know, create some sort of data.
And if we go into the developer tool here,
inspect the element, go into the Database,
you'll see that sure enough,
the notes I'm writing are pushed down
into that SQLite database.
But let's lose the connection.
Okay. No connection. No Ethernet connection.
Can you go to google.com?
Okay, good. My favorite web site is inaccessible.
We really are offline.
Let's try creating another note.
Okay, so the note continues to work.
The JavaScript's all there.
Uh, the data is being pushed into the SQL database.
Now you must be wondering, okay,
you got the data in the database,
but where is the app?
Well, let's look at the manifest
because the standard points us to a way to actually, uh,
have pointers into the storage system which high--
which, uh, point to where the code is, the JavaScript code
and the other resources that you need.
And so there you can see where the JavaScript CSS images,
uh, and other things are stored
so that when you're in an offline state,
well, you can rehydrate all those resources,
and the app just works.
Let's show you a more advanced example.
This is an Android phone,
and what you're looking at here on Android is Gmail.
It's really, really rich Gmail.
You can see the colored labels,
for those of you who are Gmail users,
you've come to know and love.
Um, as Matt moves around,
you see that floating toolbar that moves with him--
that's all implemented, uh, in this particular app,
and it's very, very fast.
You click a message, it opens up.
Here's the kicker.
Look at the top of the screen.
This is an Android device that's in offline mode.
It has no connectivity.
In fact, what you're looking at is a web app,
utilizing the great new capabilities
of the Android browser to have support
This particular app, Gmail on Android or on the iPhone,
is already shipping.
In fact, it's Google's
and really demonstrates the power of what's possible.
And as these phones get faster, these web apps
just get better and better and better.
Whether it be better JavaScript performance,
or the CPU of the phone gets better,
or the network connectivity gets faster,
these really become more and more capable,
and another example of Google
Okay, let's go back to slides.
Of course, we're not the only company who's, uh--who's--
really has invested in the web.
Another company that has pivoted their strategy
around an open web platform is Palm.
And to talk about that, I'd like to invite up Michael.
Michael Abbott, Senior Vice President of Palm.
Welcome Michael.
Michael and Greg.
Gonna talk about this, yes.
Abbott: Thanks a lot, Vic.
Uh, good morning to everyone here.
Um, I think that, uh, one of the interesting things
that I was thinking about yesterday is that
if it was a year ago, and you were at this conference,
I'm not too sure many of you would've predicted
that Palm would be at stage here at Google I/O.
And, uh, one of the key things I think why we're here
is that we share a very common vision.
Or a similar vision.
And that is indeed that the web is really the platform.
And as we step back in time from when we were designing
and architecting webOS, we were thinking through,
how could we actually enable developers
to have a program model that we're used to,
but at the same time offer access to both
services in the cloud as well as on the device?
And so what we did was we have built up a platform
with the browser as really the core construct.
And more concretely, actually using WebKit
as the core rendering engine in WebOS.
So all of the core applications
that are built as a part of WebOS--
mail, contacts, and calendar--
are all built in HTML, CSS, and JavaScript
as applications on-- in this environment.
So if you look at a little more details
of what one of these applications really look like,
you can see that we have an HTML page
that defines a layout of the application,
we have JavaScript that-- which can define transitions,
animations, access storage on the device,
and we might use CSS to style the applications.
Now, for developers we have
a framework called the Mojo framework
that allows you to style applications in beautiful ways
and at the same time be very performate.
Now, with this program model that we're offering,
certainly standards is really important to us,
And so we're gonna show you just a couple quick demos
of how we've actually
in the initial version of the platform.
So we'll switch over.
So, the first thing I'm gonna show you
is just an example of the canvas tag in our calendar application.
You can see the way we're using it
is to actually get really high-performance scrolling
as Greg actually scrolls up and down in the day view.
So that's just one example there.
And this example we're gonna show you is CSS transformations.
So this is in our music application,
and you can see that we're using CSS transformations
to rotate the album art.
Again, this application
is all built in HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
And the last example I'm gonna show you
And we're using
as a mechanism to store user's history as well as browsers.
Now, within this development environment,
there's a set of services that are on the device--
uh, we'll get to the next slide.
That we want to offer and expose up,
from the hardware in this particular case,
into that development environment.
And the Accelerometer is one of these extensions
What we've done is offered up various events
into that JavaScript run time
so, for example, events around shaking, acceleration,
and orientation, and expose those events up
into JavaScript.
Now, there are certainly other types of events like this
that--as a result of that deep integration
between the software and hardware--
makes a lotta sense,
certainly for the mobile computing platform,
and that's actually one of the key things that--
that we're interested in working with you on over time
which is how do we actually really bring in both the mobile
and the desktop development environments together.
If you look at an example of how we're actually doing
this type of integration of the applications
using these accelerometer API,
you can see that we define a set of events,
and then you as a developer can go and define
the handling of those events.
So depending on how you want to leverage the accelerometer
in your application, it's very simple to access these events
and leverage these within
that JavaScript programming environment.
So again, what we see
is really a key convergent point between the mobile platform
and the desktop platform,
and we're very interested in working with you over time
to extend all the various events and access services
from these hardware platforms into this run time.
Thank you.
[applause]
Gundrota: Thank you. Thank you.
Okay, App Cache, Database--
broadly adopted today in these browsers.
Finally, let me talk about Web Workers.
You know, as the web becomes more powerful,
and you build better and better apps
that become richer and bigger,
uh, you do run into some problems.
Problems that native applications have solved.
For example, any of you who've written applications
with large amounts of JavaScript
understand the challenge of having the UI freeze
as you do JavaScript parsing.
It's not pretty.
but unfortunately it's unavoidable
as your JavaScript gets larger and larger.
How do we solve this problem?
Well, in a native application,
you could spawn a background thread.
You could, uh, have background processing.
And that's exactly
of web workers allows you to do.
Let me show you some demos.
Let's move over to screen one. There we go.
This particular example just calculates, um,
some prime numbers.
And so we've got a couple of tabs open there.
You can see we've got the New York Times and so forth.
Uh, Matt, why don't you go ahead and start the demo?
And now try clicking on another tab.
Uh, exactly.
So the JavaScript parsing is completely hosing
not only the tab-- the UI of the tab--
but as well as the rest of the browser.
Let's redo that demo.
This time let's look at the source.
Same demo, but look at the source.
We made a change.
And you see there Matt highlighting the use
of the background processing via the Web Worker.
Let's run that same app again.
Number one, the UI is responsive,
the other tabs are responsive,
and it all just works.
Right? New capability.
Background processing in the browser from JavaScript.
That's just really, really great.
Let me--
[applause]
Hold your applause.
If you like that, wait 'til you see this.
Uh, this demo is my favorite.
Okay, it's using the canvas tag to place the boxes,
it's using the video tag to play the video,
it's using JavaScript and Web Workers
to run some background processing.
Let me tell you what's gonna happen.
We're gonna start the video, and you're gonna see a lady
walk by the vi--on the video.
JavaScript is gonna run and do motion detection,
and then draw via canvas a bounding box around the object
Gundrota: that's moving,
and it's gonna do that in the background
so the app's still responsive.
Watch this.
The boxes in the right are differentials.
How crazy is that?
Did you ever think you'd see background processing--
Uh, you'd see video motion detection
done in JavaScript in the browser?
You know, I certainly didn't.
This is just fantastic, and a great demonstration
of these capabilities all coming together,
and the kind of rich app that we can now start to build
within the browser.
So I hope you liked that.
[applause]
Let's go back to slides. Very good.
And once again, that capability,
broadly available in these modern browsers.
So I hope you've enjoyed that section of the talk.
That was about a more powerful web,
and how as an industry we are creating new capabilities
and, uh, but it's still up to us as a community
to build the applications
that take advantage of that more powerful web.
I'm going to pivot at this point,
and now talk about making it easier
to build those kind of apps
and how Google Services can help you.
Obviously if you came to last year's development conference,
or attended any of our Google Campfire Ones
or watched them online,
you know that Google's deeply interested
in making it easier for you to build web apps.
Two of our offerings in this space
have been Google App Engine and Google Web Toolkit.
Google App Engine's value proposition was very simple.
We said, let us provide the hosting for your app
so you don't have to worry about machine instances,
you don't have to worry about the app's scaling,
you don't have to carry a pager; we'll do that for you.
And we're gonna give you an update on that in a moment.
Google Web Toolkit had a different, uh, proposition.
It said, write in Java, and we'll compile down,
understand which browser's being used,
and push down the appropriate JavaScript,
and do it in a fantastic way
that allows you to target multiple browsers.
To give you an update
on Google App Engine and Google Web Toolkit,
let me invite up Andrew Bowers and Kevin Gibbs.
[applause]
Thank you, guys.
both: Thanks, Vic.
Gibbs: You know, the interest in adoption that we've seen
in Google App Engine over the past year
has been truly remarkable.
developers sign up
to use Google App Engine,
and not a single one of those developers
had to purchase or provision a server to get started.
They were able to develop their application locally
on their own machine, be it Mac, Windows, or Linux,
and leave the servers to us.
Now, our SDK is just three megabytes.
If you haven't tried out App Engine before,
I encourage you to download it. Give it a shot.
Now, since we launched App Engine last year,
we've also had
deployed on Google App Engine.
Now, often these applications have been created
by small and agile teams
like many of you in the audience here,
and they can be because with App Engine
you don't have to worry about your configuration,
your up time, or usage spikes, or re-architecting
your application once it finally starts to get popular.
In fact, we were able to put this, uh--
this policy to the test ourselves
when the White House decided to use Google Moderator,
which runs on Google App Engine,
for President Obama's live town hall event.
Despite a traffic peak
and promotions on all the major search engines and news sites,
the application scaled to meet the traffic,
and none of the other applications were affected.
Now, over the past year we've also launched
a number of features and improvement to App Engine,
including things like our SSL support,
memcache API, the system status site,
uh, access to secure data behind the firewall,
and the ability to pay for usage beyond our free quotas.
Now, we've also found that there's a number
of additional things that we'll launch to you
in the coming months.
They include things like
background processing for your jobs
and large object support for your application.
If you'd like to learn more,
I'd urge you to come to our sessions here at Google I/O
over the next two days.
Now, certainly the feature that we've launched recently
that's generated the most noise and the most buzz
is our Java language support.
The interest in our Java support since we launched it
a month and a half ago has been remarkable.
In a matter of days,
even hours since we launched our Java support,
we saw developers--many of you in the audience here today--
dive in and get not only Java frameworks
working on App Engine, but also other JVM languages.
Including things like JRuby, Groovy,
Scala, and even PHP.
And that, we thought, was truly amazing.
I'd like to say thank you
for all of you early adopters who gave us a try
and gave us the feedback with the system.
Now, we found that the demand for Java on App Engine
has been so overwhelming, and the response so positive,
we think that we're ready to take the next step
with Java on App Engine.
So I'd like to announce--
sorry, let's skip this slide.
I'd like to announce that we are opening sign-ups
for Java on App Engine as of right now.
Anyone can now log in and create a Java application immediately.
[applause]
Thank you.
Now with that, I'd like to stop telling you
about our Java support in App Engine,
and start showing you.
So I'd like to pull over Andrew Bowers.
Andrew is gonna demonstrate to you
how we have an NTN Solution for creating Java applications
using Google Web Toolkit and Google App Engine.
Andrew's gonna demonstrate to you how we think we have
a way to make applications both more scalable
and easier to use
with back-ends running on Google App Engine,
and front-ends built with Google Web Toolkit.
Andrew.
Bowers: Thanks, Kevin.
So if any of you have ever done Java development,
you've probably experienced the frustrating lag
between getting a development environment set up
and actually deploying something to the web.
And if you're working on a weekend project,
maybe you decided to go ahead and use something
like Ruby on Rails 'cause you wanted to actually
get something out there.
So we definitely recognize that pain and frustration
in our own lives, and tried to make the on-ramp to a new app
as quick as possible.
So to demonstrate, I'm going to create the starter project
from the Eclipse plug-in;
I'm gonna deploy that to the web.
And I'm gonna use Google Web Toolkit and App Engine
and hopeful--it should take me
so somewhere around there's my goal.
So here I have the Eclipse development environment.
and let's just get started.
I'm gonna go ahead and open up the new project wizard.
I'll create something called "com.google," create a package.
And I'm gonna use Google Web Toolkit and App Engine.
And this is gonna create the starter project for me.
Looks like we already had something running.
We'll go ahead and stop that.
And now I'm gonna start that on a local server.
So this is a--
Has everything I need already.
I didn't have to install Tomcat,
all I did was I installed the Google plug-in for Eclipse
into my Eclipse development environment.
That downloaded the App Engine SDK,
the Google Web Toolkit SDK, and the local development server
which mimics the production environment.
So now I have a, uh, very simple Ajax application.
It takes some text here.
It synchronously sends that to the server,
echoes the text back, as you can see,
and then gives me a little information
about the server that I'm running.
Just so we can tell that it's actually going to the server.
So if we look at the code for that...
Open up the project here.
You can see I have a client package and a server package.
Now, all of the code inside my client package
is Google Web Toolkit code
that's Java code that's going to be compiled into JavaScript
in the final step.
And it's using--
Uh, it's using widgets and it's using events
so they're abstracted away so that it'll work across browsers.
So I could change the text on the button here to "Post."
Inside my server package I have Java classes
that are grown as bytecode on the server
and you can see that I'm getting RPC,
and I'm echoing it back,
so we'll say, "Hello from Google I/O."
And we'll save that there.
Now if I go back--
So I've just edited Java code.
I'm gonna go back to my browser, I'll click "Refresh."
And I see it says "Post,"
and I see it says, "Hello from Google I/O."
So I just edited Java,
but I'm seeing those changes now on my browser.
Okay, so I've got a-a small, functioning app.
Let's go ahead and deploy that out to the web.
Go back into Eclipse, I'll go up to the deploy wizard,
and you'll notice there's an error here right now.
That's 'cause I haven't set an application ID.
So I'm gonna go to the App Engine console,
and I'll create a new application ID.
We'll say, "demoforio."
And we'll save that,
and hope no one beat me to it out there.
Okay. You're not fast enough.
Great, so we'll go back.
I had some backups just in case.
So we'll set the application ID here in the environment.
And all I need to do now
is enter in my username and password.
Then hit the "Deploy" button.
The SDK has taken care of the rest for me.
So it's going to convert that Java code
from Google Web Toolkit in the client package to JavaScript,
it's going to compile the, uh, Java code to bytecode,
for the server side stuff,
package all of that up into a web archive directory
and deploy it to the server.
There's no FTP involved by me, no server configuration;
everything's handled within the SDK.
And I could do this from the command line
if I wanted to as well.
And so now we should have a deployed app.
And hopefully within a few minutes, here.
So let's go to that demoforio.appspot.
And so I've got a fully functioning,
if not very functional, app out on the web.
[applause]
Bowers: So remember, too, that that was in Java
and it was really quick; there was no server configuration,
there was very little development configuration.
Just installed Eclipse and installed a plug-in
and it was pretty much ready to go.
Also notice that I didn't have to write
any JavaScript XHR calls.
That's because I'm using Google Web Toolkit,
and it'll handle the communication
between the client and the server for me.
So what App Engine does on the back-end
making server-side tasks easier,
Google Web Toolkit does on the front-end,
making client-side coding and development easier as well.
So if we can go back to slides...
[laughter]
So they told me I needed a marchitecture diagram.
So it's Google Web Toolkit in the front,
and App Engine in the back.
Now I want to talk about two features
that are coming up in Google Web Toolkit.
We're optimistic
bring some sanity to the browser world.
Yet you're still going to
have to develop for multiple browsers.
Now, Google Web Toolkit's inherently designed
to work across browsers,
handling the differences for you.
So you write your user interface in Java,
and then the compiler is going to handle the compiling
to the optimized, appropriate JavaScript-rich environment.
But right now there's a wrinkle in that development flow.
We encourage people to use CSS 'cause it's a powerful way
to style your apps, but if you're familiar with this,
you'll also know it's frustratingly inconsistent.
[applause]
I see some of you relate.
So it's times like these when you want to use Firebug
to figure out what the heck's going on.
Now, here's the wrinkle.
Because we have real time Java debugging
in Google Web Toolkit using a special browser,
it's meant you had to compile the JavaScript first,
then take that, go view that in Firefox,
and then look at Firebug,
and then so we had an extra step in there.
Well I'm happy to say
in the next version of Google Web Toolkit
You'll no longer have to do that.
You'll be able to debug directly in the browser.
It's also not just Firefox, it's any browser.
So let me show you a quick demo of what that looks like.
So I'm gonna go back to the project that I just created,
and I'm gonna change the launch configuration
to use the new plug-in.
So we'll take this out here.
So this is gonna start up the plug-in infrastructure.
And I'm gonna close down nightly
and start up the other version of Firefox we have here,
'cause that's what my plug-in is installed on.
Now I can navigate to my local server.
And you'll notice that I'm passing in,
uh, special query parameters
so that we know it's coming from the hosted mode.
And you can see this is the--
the app that I just had, and so now I can use Firebug
and inspect like-- like you're used to.
Okay, well, that doesn't seem too special,
but remember that what I have on the back-end is still Java.
So you can see this is Java that we're generating here.
I can make that change, go back to Firefox--
I'm not using the special browser here--
click "Refresh,"
and then I should be able to inspect that.
Let's see if we refresh again.
Or sometimes it helps to restart your server.
So let's do that. All right.
So we've got that running.
And make sure I didn't cache.
So this is going to make the development cycle a lot faster.
It's also going to work on multiple browsers as well,
so all the major browsers have plug-ins.
And there we go. There we see some changes.
[applause]
And it'll also work with other plug-ins as well.
Now, I want to talk about one more feature
that we're really excited about
in the next version of Google Web Toolkit.
With all this
you're going to find yourself writing rich user interfaces.
And if you've built apps like that before,
really large JavaScript Ajax apps,
you'll know that your JavaScript codebase is going to grow,
and it's going to grow a lot.
If we can go back to slides, please.
It's going to grow a lot as you add more functionality.
And that in turn means your users are going to wait,
and they're going to wait, and they're going to wait
for your application to finish loading.
So you need a way to split up all those JavaScript files
across multiple files so your user
can get started with your application
without having to wait for it.
However, manually splitting JavaScript
can be very tedious.
You have to get the dependencies correct,
uh, it takes a long time, and you really--
it's not something you wanna do on a Friday night.
So that's why the next version of Google Web Toolkit
we're gonna help you out with that,
and do it for you with something called,
"developer-guided code splitting,"
also known as runAsync.
Now with runAsync, what you do is specify in your code
somewhere that you're willing to accept a short pause
in exchange for the compiler being able
to functionally fragment your codebase.
So what this means is I can download code
after the initial download.
Imagine you have a settings page, it's not real--
uh, it's rarely used, not used on startup at least.
Well, there's no reason to download
that code with your initial download.
Instead you'd set a runAsync split point,
then allow that code to download in the background
after your user is up and running.
Okay, you're saying, "Andrew, that's great in theory,
but does it really work?"
Well, I'd like to leave you with some metrics
from a real world application that's using runAsync.
This is a application we'll talk more about tomorrow.
This is a graph during development
of the size of the JavaScript codebase.
So it quickly grew
as they added more functionality to the UI.
So that's--that's a lot of code to download on initial download.
Now, after runAsync, the initial download
which can then be decreased
It's going to load a lot faster.
And the best part is they didn't have to worry
about the dependencies themselves.
The compiler looked at their codebase
and handled all that for them.
So these are just a few of the features that we're adding
to Google Web Toolkit.
We're gonna be talking a lot more about the future
and the present with both App Engine
and Google Web Toolkit over the next few days,
so please stop by and join us.
Thank you.
[applause]
Thanks.
Gundrota: Great job, guys.
And as you can see, these are the URLs where you can go
to learn more or attend any of the sessions.
Of course we are very, very happy at Google
to see the developer adoption of Google services.
You go to a webpage and you see someone who's incorporated
Google YouTube, or Google News, or Google Video,
or even Google Search on their page,
and it delights us.
that we make available,
uh, to developers.
In fact, we're very proud to announce today
that we have crossed
every day
coming in to Google.
That's even a big number for us.
And so thank you for your support,
thank you for, uh, enhancing your apps with Google services.
Of course, we're not satisfied.
We wanna do more to-- to make your web apps better
and make the web even richer.
And we looked at one of our most successful models.
And that's AdSense.
There are literally hundreds of thousands of sites
that use AdSense.
And they get those Google ads on their page by nothing more
than including a little bit of JavaScript.
And so we asked ourselves, why couldn't we
take that approach for everything we were doing?
Why not make our other services that easy
to incorporate into your applications?
To demonstrate a brand-new developer product for you,
I'd like to invite up DeWitt Clinton
to walk you through that.
DeWitt, please. Welcome.
Clinton: Hey, thank you, Vic.
[applause]
Hi.
Today I'm very pleased to introduce
Google Web Elements.
Google Web Elements bring Google products
to your website using simple copy and paste.
We were inspired by the embeddable YouTube video
and AdSense, and asked ourselves,
could we apply this approach to more products?
Today I'm going to demonstrate adding Google News
and Google Maps, and Google Search
to a website using Google Web Elements.
Let's get started.
Here's a simple website we put together.
Standard two-column layout like something you'd find on Blogger,
or WordPress, or your own site.
It looks pretty good,
but I think we can make it more dynamic.
I'd like to pull in, uh, headline news from Google News,
and I'll do that with a Google Web Element.
I go to google.com/webelements,
and I select the "News" element.
And here I can choose from headlines from technology,
sports, politics, or enter my own.
I'll enter "Google."
And I'll fit it to my site.
And I copy the code,
and I go to the HTML of my site, and find the right place.
and I hit "paste."
When I go back to the page and refresh,
Google News is already live.
I'd like to add now a map
to Moscone and the developer conference.
So I go to google.com/webelements,
I go to the "Maps" element,
I type in, "Moscone Center."
And we're here for Google I/O.
And I like the terrain view.
And again, I copy the code,
I go to my template,
Clinton: and I paste it in wherever I want.
Refresh, and we're already live.
Now, even a small--thank you.
[applause]
Now, even a small site like this one can benefit from search.
I can do that with the Google Custom Search element.
I'll go to google.com/webelements,
click the "Custom Search" element,
and right now I don't need to do anything more.
The Custom Search element will automatically configure itself
to search just the content of my site.
So all I have to do is copy--
and I think you're seeing the pattern here--
paste,
and the search box appears.
I'm going to do a test search.
Looks good.
However, since the Custom Search element
is built on top of the Ajax search APIs,
I can apply the styling rules and custom JavaScript
however I like to make it fit my site.
I move the search box over here, and there we go.
So I've added maps, news, and search
all in about three minutes.
And my site's certainly more dynamic,
but I'd like to make it more interactive.
I'd like to make it social.
I can do that with the Google Conversation element.
The Google Conversation element allows visitors to my site
to post comments and videos
and hold a conversation about whatever topic I choose.
So, in fact, I will choose Google I/O as a topic.
And I will copy the code,
I will paste it into the site,
and I will refresh.
And our conversation is live.
Hello, Google--
Oops.
Google I/O.
So we've seen, just using copy and paste,
adding search, news, maps, and conversations to the website
thanks to Google Web Elements.
Google Web Elements are available today
at google.com/webelements.
Thank you. Thank you, Vic.
[applause]
Gundrota: Copy/paste development.
We think that's really going to make it easier.
Next I'd like to talk about Android.
Eric mentioned it in his opening remarks.
We couldn't be happier with the progress that we've made
in a little over just half a year
since Android's been introduced.
In those brief, few months, we've had three versions out,
including the latest version last week
We've had ten carriers and--
including apps like the one we demonstrated on Android earlier,
using the powerful capability of its browser.
And on average we're seeing users of Android
to their device.
And so the ecosystem is really working,
browser share is just fantastic and fun to watch,
and we thank you for your support.
What we'd like to do next, though,
is show you a sneak peek into what's coming next on Android,
and for that I'd like to invite up Romain Guy.
Romain, please, why don't you show us what's coming next.
Guy: Thank you, Vic.
[applause]
the Android team is already
hard at work on the next version of Android,
and we code named it "Donut."
You may have heard of it on the Web already.
And today I want to show you two exciting, new features
that will ship as part of Donut.
First, we want to make search more useful and more powerful
both for users and developers alike.
For users, we want-- we want them to be able,
from a single query, to be able to search the Web,
their contacts, their bookmarks,
their application, and their music.
But let me show you what it looks like.
So here I have an Android device.
And on my home screen, when I click the search widget,
I can initiate a new search.
And if I start typing,
the device automatically looks
for my applications or my contacts.
We can also look for Web results.
So if we're hungry for pizza,
we can search the Web for that.
But we decided that the search UI
could be a lot more than that.
The search UI can also act
as a brand-new launcher for you as a user.
Every time I click a search result,
the system remembers what I did with that search result,
and the more I use my device, the more the--the--
the device will know about me, about what I do every day,
about my common tasks.
And what happens is every time I start a new search,
I get pre-populated results.
So here, for instance, last time I did a search
I clicked the calendar application.
And I see here the result
that matters to me on a day-to-day basis.
So this is going to be an awesome feature
'cause I know that in this part of the UI
I will always have access to the thing
that matters to me as a user.
But there's more.
We want the search UI to become a powerful tool
for your applications.
And with just a few lines of code,
your application can populate more results in the search UI.
And I have a simple example here.
I wrote an application for myself,
just a list of books I've read,
and I wanted to be able to quickly search
my library from the home screen.
So with just a couple lines of XML,
I am now able to add my search results to this UI.
And if I type the name of one of my favorite authors,
I can see his books appearing in my search UI.
And you can see search results from the Web--
more books and more Web results.
So we're really excited about this feature
because you guys are creating the content.
You have the application, you have content
that the Android platform doesn't have,
and we can't wait to see what you're going to do with it
and what you're going to put in this UI.
Next, we wanted to add a new API--
something that you developers have widely requested.
a new speech recognition API
that lets you control the device
without any physical interaction.
Now, the problem is the device cannot interact with you.
So we're introducing a new Text-to-Speech API
that lets the device, you know, read text to you,
or give you a result, or, you know,
turn-by-turn navigation
if you're writing a GPS application.
And I have a simple demo here.
We modified the Translate application
that you can find on the Android market,
and we added the Text-to-Speech API.
So, for instance, here, if I want to translate a sentence
from English to French, and I click the "Translate" button...
computer voice: Bienvenue à San Francisco.
Guy: The device reads the sentence to me.
And we're shipping-- we're going to ship Donut
with several voice packs for different languages,
so in any language the user will get the right accent
so they will be able to understand
what the device is saying perfectly.
So, for instance, in German...
computer voice: Willkommen in San Francisco.
Guy: Or even in English.
As I--as you can see,
we have two different versions in English.
computer voice: Welcome to San Francisco.
Guy: So we're really excited...
[applause]
We're really excited about these APIs
'cause we know that you guys
are going to do great things with it.
But it gets even better.
We're shipping a new text-to-speech API in Donut,
but we're also going to ship the text-to-speech engine,
and thanks to SVOX, that engine will be open source.
So as part of the Android platform,
any Android device will have an open-source
text-to-speech engine of high quality
like you just heard right now.
Finally, I want to show you a small experiment
that we've been working on in the Android team.
We--you know, we recognize that sometimes
finding a specific item in a long list of data--
for instance, I have several hundred contacts--
and finding one item in that list
can be, you know, pretty painful.
So we have different solutions to address that issue.
We have search,
we have search on the home screen,
you can filter your list
when you're in a contact application,
we have a fast scroll widget--
many different ways to do it.
But we wanted something new, something more interesting
and that was a little more fun to use.
So I have a small demo for you here.
Wouldn't it be cool if I could
just launch my contact application
and start drawing on the screen to filter my list?
And I keep-- and I can keep going,
and the device just recognizes the handwriting
and filters the list.
Instead of filtering, if you prefer,
you can simply jump to an item.
So, for instance, in the music application,
I can jump directly to a certain position in the list.
We care about the user experience,
but we also care about the developer experience.
And we hope that with those new APIs
that we're introducing in Donut
there will be more--
you are going to come up with awesome applications
that will make Android a more exciting platform.
Thank you, Vic.
Gundrota: Thank you very much, Romain, thank you.
[applause]
Well, folks, we covered quite a bit of ground.
First of all, you heard about our call to action for HTML--
Google's commitment to make applications
and we hope you join us.
We talked about App Engine
being opened up for Java sign-ups.
We gave you a sneak peek at GWT
and what's coming next-- in the next version there.
We introduced Google Web Elements--
copy/paste development.
And finally, we gave you a sneak peek
at what's coming next in Android.
We have three more things and one final spot.
Gundrota: First I'd like to announce that we are--
have part two of the Android Developer Challenge
being announced today.
The details are located at that url.
We will take submissions for the contest in August,
judging will occur through the fall,
and we'll announce our winners at the end of fall.
This time we've learned a few things from American Idol,
and so we will have user votes as part of the judging,
and we think this contest
is going to be really, really exciting.
Number two, I'd like to announce
that we're going to give away--
to every conference attendee today,
which contains a link to the SDK documentation...
[laughter]
And a few more surprises...
including an Android phone.
[cheers and applause]
This...
I think, you know, we realized
that you could go download the SDK,
you could use the emulator,
but nothing beats having a real device.
And I've always wanted an Oprah moment,
so for you, and you, and you.
[applause]
There's one more thing.
This is an unlocked device that'll be available.
In addition, we went one step further.
Included in every device
will be a SIM that gives you
and thousands of hours
And so we realized some of you don't have a SIM
to get started tonight, you might have a CDMA phone,
but we think this is a nice way
to get started on you exploring the platform.
[cheers and applause]
It's our small way of saying
thank you for supporting our conference as well.
I'd like to conclude by just making
a few more quick announcements.
If you thought that surprise was fun,
we have another surprise for you.
Please don't miss tomorrow's keynote.
Tomorrow's keynote, I think, will surprise many of you
with some exciting things that have not yet leaked,
and we're so excited about that.
[laughter]
So you'll enjoy that.
Number two, picking up your device--
you can pick up your device starting this afternoon
throughout the entire conference.
So you don't have to go rush.
You don't have to go queue up in line right now.
Go to your sessions, and in the afternoon
at the registration area,
we'll start giving out
And we'll continue that through the party tonight.
So don't miss the after hours party.
We're going to have some great DJs.
Like last year, we're going to have a lot of fun.
And, of course, many Googlers
will be there to interact with you.
So once again, thank you for attending the keynote,
enjoy the conference,
and thank you for supporting Google I/O.
[cheers and applause]
recorded male voice: Welcome to Google I/O.